there have been rumors about A New
Nightmare on Elm Street in development
by Blum House and it all comes from this
tweet it says A Nightmare on Elm Street
recall is in development blumhouse has
been secretly working on making a recall
of the first entry of The Saga the
Revival is high priority we don't have a
date yet but we shouldn't expect it to
be so far away but seeing this tweet
really got me thinking about the
possibilities for a blumhouse Revival of
a Nightmare on Elm Street you have to
believe that there's a possibility that
this is going to be a recall Trilogy
like what they did with the Halloween
franchise with Halloween 2018 Halloween
kills and Halloween ends and of course
the big question is who's going to play
Freddy Krueger now I know recently the
original Freddy Krueger Robert England
has gone on record where he said I'm too
old and thick to play Freddie now so
stranger things season four if you
haven't seen it plays very much like a
Nightmare on Elm Street movie and Robert
England actually does make an appearance
in stranger things season four but
knowing blumhouse I'm sure they're gonna
try to get England back it could be a
scenario where you know they shoot him
in the close-ups and they have a stunt
actor doing all of the crazy stuff in
the dream sequences obviously there's a
lot of makeup involved in that so it
should be pretty easy to hide that kind
of stuff I want to hear your thoughts
and dreams about a possible New
Nightmare on Elm Street so let me know
in the comments